Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Ah oui ! Non mais il faut
que je vous explique.
Si je m’apprête à souffler cette bougie,
c’est pour célébrer un événement
très important pour moi
qui a eu lieu il y a deux ans,
jour pour jour,
puisque c’était la fin de mes cinq mois
de chimiothérapie
pour traiter mon cancer du sein.
Pourtant, je ne suis pas le genre de
femme préférée du cancer du sein,
puisqu’en général, il est plus attiré
vers des femmes plus matures,
au-delà de 50 ans.
Mais de temps en temps, il fait exception
et vient squatter chez les plus jeunes.
J’ai donc rencontré mon cancer du sein
à 34 ans, en septembre 2020.
À ce moment-là, avec Damien, mon conjoint,
on était en plein parcours
de procréation médicalement assistée
ou PMA pour les intimes.
Un bébé éprouvette en projet donc,
parce que Damien aussi a eu un cancer,
de la lymphe, lui, quand il avait 20 ans.
Voilà.
Donc vous vous demandez sûrement,
mais comment est-ce qu’on se rend compte
qu’on a un cancer à 34 ans ?
Eh bien, en fait, dans ma famille,
le cancer est à proprement parler
dans notre ADN.
Pour que ce soit tout à fait clair,
je vous ai préparé un petit schéma
pour vous expliquer.
Donc, du côté de ma mère,
on compte quatre filles :
Danielle, Claude, Micheline et Monique.
En 1986, quand ma mère, Monique,
est enceinte de son troisième
et dernier enfant, ici présente,
sa sœur Claude lui annonce
qu’elle a un cancer des ovaires.
À ce moment-là, donc,
dans les conversations familiales,
j’entends les mots cancer, chimiothérapie,
sans y mettre de sens particulier.
En 1996,
j’ai dix ans quand ma tante,
Claude, décède.
Alors je ne mets pas plus
de sens sur ces mots.
Mais à dix ans, on est suffisamment grande
pour être profondément triste.
En 1998, ma tante Micheline
parle à mes parents
d’une sorte de boule
qu’elle sent dans son sein.
Quelque temps plus tard,
elle commence des traitements
pour soigner un cancer du sein.
Malheureusement,
les traitements n’y feront rien
puisque Micheline décède en 2004 à 52 ans.
À ce moment-là, moi j’en ai 18
et je commence à comprendre un peu plus
ce que signifie le mot cancer.
En 2009, c’est au tour de ma mère d’entrer
en coloc avec un cancer des ovaires.
Pendant quatre ans,
les traitements sont rudes.
Mais aujourd’hui, son principal souci,
c’est qu’il y ait assez de crêpes
pour ses quatre petits-enfants.
Quant à ma tante Danielle,
l’aînée des quatre filles,
elle déclare un cancer du sein
en 2011 à 70 ans.
Un cancer pris en charge à temps,
soigné et guéri.
Et à l’heure où je vous parle,
je pense que Danielle doit être en train
de convaincre ma mère que oui,
trois kilos de crêpes pour
quatre petits-enfants, bon, ça va.
Ni ma mère ni mes tantes ne pouvaient
imaginer avoir un problème génétique
qui pourrait expliquer en partie
le développement de leur cancer.
Et pour cause, ce problème génétique,
c’est une mutation sur le gène BRCA1,
pour Breast Cancer 1,
qui a été découverte en 1994.
Si ces quatre lettres
vous disent quelque chose,
c’est peut-être parce qu’Angelina Jolie
en a parlé il y a dix ans.
Elle aussi est concernée
par cette mutation
et elle s’est fait opérer
de façon préventive des seins
pour éviter le développement d’un cancer.
En fait, dans notre corps, on compte
plusieurs milliards de cellules.
À l’intérieur de ces cellules,
dans le noyau se trouve notre ADN et
c’est dans l’ADN qu’on retrouve les gènes.
Le gène BRCA1 est l’un des 21 000
gènes qui composent notre ADN.
On a tous ce gène, hommes et femmes, mais
chez certaines personnes, il est muté,
abîmé, en quelque sorte.
Ce qui fait qu’il ne peut pas empêcher
le développement d’un cancer
au niveau des seins et des ovaires.
Quand on porte la mutation
au niveau du gène BRCA1,
on a 80 % de risque de développer
un cancer à ce niveau-là.
Durant ses traitements,
ma mère a donc fait ce test génétique
qui a révélé qu’elle était
porteuse de cette mutation.
Et un peu avant mes 30 ans,
j’ai moi aussi fait ce test génétique
qui a révélé que j’étais porteuse
de cette mutation.
Au moment de l’annonce, je me rappelle
que la généticienne m’a dit deux choses.
La première, c'est que la recherche
sur le cancer du sein
avance presque tous les jours.
Et la deuxième, c’est que l’idée
n’était pas d’éviter un cancer
parce que c’est juste impossible,
mais d’arriver au plus tôt de son
développement, si jamais il se présente.
Et dans ce cas-là, la meilleure arme,
c’est le dépistage.
C'est ce que j'ai fait, moi, tous
les ans jusqu'en septembre 2020.
J’ai donc passé
une IRM mammaire de contrôle
et on a repéré une anomalie
au niveau du sein droit.
On a donc fait une biopsie pour analyser
ce qu'il y avait à l'intérieur.
Et là, il a fallu attendre dix jours
pour avoir les résultats.
Dix jours.
On a eu rendez-vous avec une chirurgienne
de l’Institut Curie, avec Damien.
On s’est assis et elle nous a dit :
« Il y a un cancer du sein.
Il va falloir qu’on s’en occupe. »
À 34 ans, je voulais un bébé,
j’ai eu un cancer.
S'en est suivi le fameux
protocole de soins.
Donc, en ce qui me concerne,
une chirurgie pour commencer,
une mastectomie donc, qui est l’ablation
totale de la glande mammaire,
parce que le cancer était très agressif,
donc il valait mieux être radical.
Et dans le même temps opératoire,
j’ai pu bénéficier de ce qui s’appelle
une reconstruction immédiate par prothèse,
ce qui n'est pas toujours possible.
Ensuite, au programme :
16 séances de chimiothérapie
et 25 séances de radiothérapie.
Alors, la chimiothérapie.
S’il y avait bien un traitement
que je redoutais, c’était celui-là.
Et je me rappelle évidemment très bien
la toute première séance avec l’infirmière
qui m'installe et qui commence à
m'expliquer tous les effets secondaires
qu'il peut y avoir et surtout
comment réagir en fonction.
Donc j’écoute, j’attends qu’elle termine
et à un moment, à la fin donc,
je la regarde et je lui demande :
«Mais ça peut bien se passer aussi ?»
Et un peu étonnée, elle me regarde
et elle me dit :
«Oui, ça peut bien se passer aussi.»
Il faut dire que pendant tout ce parcours,
j’ai une équipe assez formidable
de supporters à mes côtés,
avec Damien en chef de file bien sûr,
mes parents, mon frère, ma sœur,
ma famille, ma belle-famille, mes amis
et j’ai aussi des projets.
Le premier, c’est une formation
de journaliste que j’avais repérée
trois mois avant de tomber malade.
Et je me souviens [de]
la première réaction de Damien
quand on nous a annoncé
que j’avais un cancer.
Il a dit : «D’accord, donc,
il y aura de la chimio.
Mais y a-t-il une contre-indication
pour que Sophie fasse
une formation de journaliste ?»
Comme quoi, quand on est passé par là,
il y a peut-être des mots qui
nous font un peu moins peur,
mais je pense que c’était aussi une façon
de s’accrocher à quelque chose de positif.
Mon deuxième projet, pas du tout prévu,
parce que totalement lié à cette épreuve,
c’est que tout le long de mon parcours,
j’ai enregistré des notes vocales sur
mon téléphone, pour en faire un podcast.
Au moment où on m’a annoncé
que j’avais un cancer,
il y avait plein d’informations à retenir
et par réflexe, j’ai enregistré,
comme des post-it vocaux.
Et la veille de l’opération, point de
départ pour moi des traitements,
c’est Damien qui m’a dit :
«Mais enregistre ce que tu vis,
tu sais faire, il faut raconter,
il faut documenter ce genre de parcours
parce que ça peut aider des malades
et des personnes qui accompagnent
aussi ces malades.»
Donc, le matin de l’opération,
j’ai commencé à enregistrer
et un an plus tard, j’ai repris toutes
ces notes pour en faire un podcast,
que j’ai appelé « My Boob Story ».
(Vidéo)(Voix de Sophie Hoffman)
Vendredi 2 octobre 2020, épisode un.
Alors, il est 5h30 du matin.
C’est le jour de ma chirurgie
pour retirer mon cancer du sein.
(Bip) Premier étage.
Voix : Vous pouvez y aller ?
SH : Ben oui.
Voix 2 : Bonjour. Vous êtes madame ?
SH : Hoffman Sophie.
Voix 2 : Venez avec moi.
SH : Jeudi 19 novembre 2020, épisode 36.
Il est 9h 52 et, clairement c’est...
aujourd’hui où je vais raser mes cheveux.
J’attends que Damien raccroche
de sa conversation téléphonique.
(Bip) (Bruit du rasoir)
SH : J’ai trop peur.
Damien : Mais peur de quoi ?
Tu te coupes les cheveux.
SH : Damien, coiffeur pour dames.
Oh la la !
(Musique disco)
(Rit)
C’est pas possible !
Oh le carnage !
Oh la la la !
Le carnage quoi !
Il n’y a pas d’autres mots !
(Bip) SH : Mercredi 14 octobre 2020,
Épisode 9.
J’ai rêvé que je sortais
avec Michel Cymes.
Voilà (Rit), déjà, c’est drôle.
Je ne lui avais pas dit, en fait,
que j’avais un cancer du sein.
Et après, je me retrouvais
dans une espèce de zoo.
Et là, je sortais avec Didier Bourdon.
(Bip) Mardi 16 mars 2020, épisode 108.
J’ai fini la chimio quoi !
Ouiiiii ! Ah ! La vache !
Seize séances de chimio.
Il y a encore pas mal d’étapes,
Mais cette partie-là, la vache !
C’est fini quoi !
SH sur scène :
Le titre complet de ce podcast,
c’est : « My Boop Story, le journal
optimiste de mon cancer du sein. »
Pourquoi optimiste ?
C'est vrai que ça peut paraître
un peu bizarre.
Eh bien, parce que je pense que
je suis comme ça, un peu, de base.
Et aussi parce que j'ai assez vite
considéré que j'avais beaucoup de chance
d'être prise en charge tôt par une équipe
médicale compétente et à l'écoute.
Et c’est vrai que j’ai été très touchée
aussi par l’idée qu’on fasse tout
pour me sauver la vie
alors que finalement, les médecins qui
me soignaient, ne me connaissaient pas.
Donc, journal optimiste mais pas positif.
Je pense que c’est vraiment important
de faire la différence,
parce que, à choisir, j’aurais préféré
ne pas avoir de cancer.
J’aurais préféré ne pas perdre mes seins,
ne pas perdre mes cheveux,
ne pas inquiéter mes proches,
ne pas souffrir et ne pas attendre
l’autorisation de pouvoir faire un enfant
sans que ma vie soit mise en danger.
Mais on ne peut pas faire en sorte
que les choses n'arrivent pas.
Alors, autant mettre le plus de sens
possible sur cette expérience particulière
qui m’a permis aussi de réaliser
qu’avoir un corps
qui peut marcher
et respirer sans difficulté,
c’est avoir une chance inouïe.
Et tant pis si c’est naïf de le dire,
je le pense !
En racontant cette expérience,
au-delà du partage que j’espère
le plus utile possible,
j’ai aussi voulu dire qu’on pouvait
s’accomplir après une telle épreuve.
On peut trouver sa voie,
affirmer sa vocation.
Mon cancer du sein m’a permis
de savoir un peu plus qui j’étais
et il m’a démontré que, quoi qu’il arrive,
et dans n’importe quelle situation,
oui, ça peut aussi bien se passer.
(Souffle sur la bougie)
(Applaudissements)